la tirelire a le sourire et pour cause
cette boucherie restée ouverte durant
tout le confinement a fait le plein on a
progressé + plus de 100 % sur le mois
d'avril mois de mai plus de 100 % sans
problème
j'étais obligé de créer des emplois et
embaucher une caissière
d'après une société d'intérim pour nous
aider port du masque obligatoire
solutions hydro alcooliques à
disposition et sens de circulation
un protocole sanitaire pour rassurer les
clients qui viennent aussi pour la
qualité de la viande française fut très
réticent sur la production industrielle
donc c'est pour ça que je préfère venir
à la boucherie de mon quartier
la hausse de la consommation locale cet
éleveur d'auffargis la constate aussi sa
spécificité
les races anciennes est moins présente
sur le marché pour une diversité des
viandes
le tout dans un souci de bien-être des
animaux la demande est complètement
exponentielle en fait aujourd'hui on
refuse à peu près dix ou vingt fois par
rapport à notre production on pourrait
vendre oui au moins 20 fois plus et on
n'aura pas assez de naissance pour
compenser tout cela donc aujourd'hui je
viens de me retourner vers des voisins
agriculteurs qui ont eu beaucoup de
naissances pour racheter les veaux au
sevrage en tout cas aujourd'hui être
présent sur le circuit des acheteurs en
plus de cette hausse de la demande
la ferme de la petite aurait dû
s'occuper de beaucoup de naissances des
prêts confiné mais pas reposer d'après
une étude opinionway sept français sur
dix estiment que cette crise sanitaire
est l'illustration qu'il faut changer
nos modes de consommation pour des
produits plus responsable